وإشارتنا ليست رائعة ،
لذا أحذرك فقط من ذلك ،
لكن يمكنك أن ترى
هذا
نحن هناك مثل سياراتنا العسكرية
هناك نوع من منطقة الاحتجاز هنا
حيث يوجد الكثير من
الأشخاص وهناك العديد من مناطق الاحتجاز هذه
لقد كانوا ينتظرون هنا لأنني
لا أعرف حوالي ثلاث
ساعات الجو حار جدًا
ولا يوجد ظل
هناك ماء ولكني أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكاننا
الاقتراب قليلاً حتى
وإلقاء نظرة فقط ترى أطفالًا
مستلقين على الأرض هنا
تخيل
التواجد هنا مع عائلتك
لمدة يومين في الشمس الحارقة في
محاولة لرعاية أطفالك
دون أي إحساس
بما سيحدث في المستقبل
عندما تصل إلى أمريكا ،
تحدثت إلى امرأة
انفصلت بالفعل عن
عائلتها  بالداخل هنا
ولكن بقية أفراد عائلتها
كانوا عالقين
خارج القاعدة ،
فلا توجد
آلية للتعامل مع مثل هذا الموقف
إذا فقدت عائلتك فقد فقدت عائلتك ،
فلا توجد طريقة لإعادة الاتصال بالناس في
هذا الشيء هناك  لا توجد طريقة
لإحضارهم من البوابة الأمامية
بصراحة لا توجد طريقة لإنقاذ أي شخص
من الكهف الأمامي ، إنه البقاء
للأصلح
[موسيقى]